it's free it's free it's
free attention is the number one asset I
don't know if anybody's paying attention
to what's going on in social media the
first decade of social media was more
like email marketing you had a build an
audience then you would post and a small
percentage of them would see it just
like email right you get 10,000 people
on an email you get 25% open rate d d d
same with social that's not what social
is now we're now living in the tiktock
ification of all social media which
means your individual post the people in
this room who've never posted once post
tomorrow with zero followers and it may
get five ,000 views cuz it clicked on
the algorithm because the first 10
people that it randomly showed it to
three of them thought it was good and
Away you went this is the greatest
opportun it's free it's free
it's
free